I have a very strange video that is quickly
becoming one of my favorite clips of the week.
This is I don't even know how to explain this.
Donald Trump did an event yesterday instead
of just hiding.
It was good to see him do something.
He did a Presidential Medal of Freedom ceremony
for Dan Gable, who's a wrestler and coach.
And as the event was sort of winding down,
the press assembled and was starting to ask
Trump questions.
And in the video I'm going to play for you,
you will hear a question asked of Donald Trump
about whether he will go to Joe Biden's inauguration.
And Trump just sort of looked around confused,
I guess, realized he didn't want to answer
that question and just walked out of the room.
And you can tell from the video that people
are confused about why Donald Trump is leaving.
And the camera, weirdly cuts to Dan Gable,
who's the presidential medal honoree, who
looks very confused and says he's gone because
clearly no one expected such an abrupt ending
to this event at some of the strangest behavior
we've seen.
Take a look at this.
It's just absolute gold.
Of course, about the inauguration.
Fact, I'm Bill Barker.
Congratulations on everything.
It really seems like the Curb Your Enthusiasm
theme should be playing as Donald Trump walks
out, it's comical and bizarre and unexplainable
all at once.
And the simplest explanation is Trump.
Trump continues not to want to answer questions
like do you admit you lost?
And do you concede that Joe Biden will be
president and will you be going to the inauguration?
And there was really no way to stay in the
room without answering the questions as far
as Trump was concerned.
But the truth is, a real president could have
handled this very easily and stayed in the
room without answering those questions.
Trump could have said, hey, listen, guys,
we're here today to honor Dan.
We're celebrating Dan's incredible accomplishments.
I don't know what they are, but but he presumably
does.
I'm just not familiar with Dan Gable.
And he could say this isn't the time for politics.
It's not a time for questions.
Thank you very much.
You're still avoiding the questions, but you're
doing it in a slightly more reasonable way.
Trump can't do it, or at least he doesn't
behave in that way.
And instead, just kind of bizarrely wanders
off, leaving a room full of people.
And everything about this event was it was
a total farce.
At one point, while the event is going on,
there's a little kid laying down.
Looks like he's sleeping in the back of the
Oval Office or whatever room.
This was an all completely bizarre.
And of course, Trump supporters will defend
him no matter what and say, well, listen,
the fake news media was throwing unfair mean
questions at him.
It was presidential harassment.
And if you think that's crazy, Dan Gable was
actually interviewed this morning about this
bizarre event.
And he essentially said that, which was Trump
didn't want to answer those questions.
Truly strange times.
Take a look.
I think Donald Trump really respects me.
He's always been humbled in front of me.
He's never made me mad.
He might have walked out of the press conference
a little bit yesterday, a little bit perturbed
with a couple of news people, newspaper people.
But but, hey, I was having a great time.
He left you in the office by yourself with
your family.
So that's OK.
He he he was didn't like what was going on.
He said it was about me and it wasn't about
him.
So he's I'm out of there.
You got it.
No, I hear you.
And you have the matter with you.
I, I do.
Right here.
Can we sit right here.
Yeah.
Yeah, right here.
It's it's President's Medal of Freedom right
here.
Yeah.
So what a weird timeline that we are in.
And I know some people have been writing to
me saying Trump is comedy gold.
David, I'm really going to miss Trump when
he leaves office.
Stuff like this, I guess, is funny in a in
a relatively benign way.
And I will sort of miss it.
But the country and the world are going to
be so much better off with Trump gone and
we're down to just six weeks.
We're
all looking forward to it.